Macario congratulations maybe first the
the first classical game where do you
think he went wrong in my notes I had
this rooks e85 might have been the
critical mistake what do you think I
mean I'm not so sure I think it was more
or less close to equal maybe very slight
advantage for me um around like moved 20
and okay I think if I go rook d1
probably it's a better version maybe
quite a bit better than the game instead
of going east first but even after East
six I thought it was a small advantage
and I mean Mickey was also a little bit
low on time so it kind of went wrong but
I have fun with correct play it's
probably a draw but there's always a
little bit of initiative a little bit of
pressure so it wasn't that easy and
fortunately for me you know Mickey
didn't quite find the best way to defend
and I was able to win the first
classical game which of course I mean
it's very important in general
especially when you're white um yeah and
then today I I don't know what was going
on I mean I thought I was completely
fine and then make you found this great
b4 idea I don't I I mean I completely
overlooked it I thought it was a very
nice idea to at least create some play
but maybe 92 was wrong from Mickey I
think if it doesn't go 90 - maybe 93 or
there's some maybe some other ideas
perhaps it's still maybe a game because
after 92 it just simplifies and there
really is a nothing nothing left to play
for for for white okay of course I have
to go back to with to the other day the
Armageddon and and the appeal by your
opponent yet sometime maybe to reflect
on it what is your comment on what
everything that happened there well okay
I mean for starters let's be clear to
the people who want to say that you know
it's it's some way of messing with with
yarn that's not the case at all frankly
speaking people have to understand that
you know I come from America and
according to American rules as far as I
know it's still legal even to castle
both hands so there's there's no ill
intention certainly from that I mean the
fact the fact that yon chose to take it
beyond that and
you know think that I was you know
intentionally trying to mess with his
head or do something crazy it's just you
know a little bit disappointing honestly
because I thought you know we plead
played a great match we both did
actually um create you know at the
critical moment and the second second
10-minute game I think it was when I had
won the first one he found this
brilliant work t2 idea and I lost and
then you know then he took the advantage
in the blitz and I want to very uh you
know I played a great great second blitz
camp to force Armageddon so um now it's
a bit disappointing that that he took it
that way but but that being said of
course it was not intentional and and
just a matter of the fact that I'm used
to playing in the US and and to go
further on that point you know there was
there's another example it wasn't a
castling but there was a game I played
against Boris grachov in the world blitz
championship and I think it was 2011
where I pushed upon to the eighth-ranked
and I lost the game against them so you
know some people think it's some kind of
intentional thing or you know it's I'm
trying to gain some advantage that's not
the case at all simply that I'm used to
playing with us rules and of course I
should should know that the rules are
not the same for fidei events but that
being said I mean after you've been
playing for five and a half hours and so
many wild swings many things can happen
so that's you know that's how it goes
okay your next opponent will be I think
it'll be Yakov encore Eliana I think but
I'm not certain who do you prefer um
I doesn't doesn't matter to me really I
mean they're both very strong opponents
obviously I'm much more familiar with
Dmitri because I'd played him in the
feed a Grand Prix a couple of times um
but I think I mean I played Pavel I
think in like Linares and maybe mm I
don't know 2002 2003 I mean a different
lifetime ago so I'm most familiar with
his his games as well but to me it
doesn't make a difference all that
matters right now is I get to relax and
enjoy rustics I mean the last couple
matches have been very stressful